Wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus den usa jetzt ein bluttest entwickelt mit dem sich ein großteil der
tumorerkrankung in einem sehr frühen stadium erkennen lassen dass ist genau das an dem
forschungsteams weltweit seit jahren tüfteln ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zu diesem bluttest der wirklich
Weltweit für aufsehen sorgt was kann er wirklich und bedeutet dass jetzt das wär kriegs endgültig
Den kampf wirklich an sagen können jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Schon lange sind forschungsteams auf der suche nach methoden die es möglich machen die diagnose von krebs alleine auf der grundlage einer
blutprobe
Zu stellen und das möglichst früh damit der kampf auch gegen die typischen krebsarten nicht schon gleich mit der diagnose verloren ist seit
2016 gibt es in der schweiz ein bluttest mit dem man
darmkrebs diagnostizieren kann die usa haben, nachgezogen
2017 den ersten blutbasierten screening test zum nachweis von darmkrebs auf den markt gelassen das alles erscheint aber wirklich klein
gegen das aktuelle forschungsergebnisse dass in der wirklich renommierten fachzeitschrift science
Präsentiert wird ein forschungsteam der columbia university stellt darin eine neue methode zur früherkennung von krebs vor und jetzt haltet euch fest
Demnach sei es möglich gleich acht und damit sind wirklich ein großteil der krebsarten
dabei in einem frühen erkrankungs starken nachzuweisen tumore in brust lunge bauchspeicheldrüse
magen leber
eierstöcken darm und speiseröhre das klingt alles wirklich erst einmal war
Doch wie genau soll das funktionieren und ist diese publikation tatsächlich seriös das forschungsteam nutzt für die sogenannte
flüssig biopsie liquid biopsie zum verständnis wenn größere tumore entstehen
Zerfallen auf krebszellen die dann ins blut ausgeschwemmt werden dazu gehören auch proteine die als tumor marker schon heutzutage
Genutzt werden, um den krankheitsverlauf zu kontrollieren aber auch. Dna bruchstücke werden frei die dann
Im blut zirkulieren der neue bluttest mit dem namen cancers sieg also krebs suche kombiniert die suche nach, acht
charakteristischen proteinen mit der suche nach der dna von 16
krebsarten die beteiligten forscherinnen und forscher glauben dass der test später nur etwa 500 us-dollar kosten wird das
weniger geld als eine darmspiegelung in den usa käufer dafür
notwendig
Einzig und allein eine einzige blutprobe der test wurde bislang an rund 1000 patientinnen und patienten durchgeführt die meisten dem start um zwei oder drei
und tatsächlich die
sensitivität der gesamtgruppe lag bei den acht krebsarten
Im gesamten bei 70 prozent das heißt durch die anwendung des tests wurde bei 70 prozent der patienten patienten die erkrankungen tatsächlich korrekt erkannt
weiter zeigte sich dass der test zuverlässige ergebnisse
Liefert je weiter die krebserkrankung fortgeschritten war besonders hoch weil die trefferquote bei r stock und lungenkrebs
98 prozent der erkrankungen wurden auf grundlage des blutes zu identifizieren anders dagegen sah es bei den brustkrebs
Patientinnen aus hier wurden anhand der blutproben nur ein drittel der erkrankten erkannt dazu kommt in einer kontrollgruppe wurden sieben von 800 personen als
krebskrank identifiziert
fälschlicherweise denn sie waren absolut gesund
andere expertinnen und experten weltweit sehen die studie deswegen auch durchaus kritisch ein großes manko sei eben die hohe gefahr für falsche positive
testergebnis
Im klartext es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass gesunde menschen die diagnose krebs bekommen das führe zu unnötigen und
kostspieligen untersuchungen und zu einer großen verunsicherung in der bevölkerung aber auch ärzte und ärztinnen
könnten verunsichert werden und der etablierte vorsorge methoden wie etwa mammographien oder darmspiegelungen weniger nutzen das würde
im schlimmsten fall bedeuten dass eine krebserkrankung
unerkannt bleibt und für den patienten oder den patienten tödlich endet von der ag molekularpathologie
der deutschen gesellschaft für pathologie dgp heißt es in einem offiziellen statement
Um die methode anzuerkennen sei es notwendig zitat eine einzelne an krebs erkrankten personen ohne symptome
Aus mehreren hundert gesunden personen und personen mit anderen erkrankungen korrekt erkannt werden und das ist bisher nicht der fall
Trotzdem ist es natürlich wahnsinnig spannend und ein absolut sensationell ansatz wenn er als erstes neues zum thema krebsbehandlung
Zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allem
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert um am anfang gibt es noch ein kleines goodie und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
glocke vergessen wie geht s weiter dafür draufklicken mit krebs mit smartphone diagnostizieren noch ein anderer
revolutionäre ansatz ansonsten bis dann eben
Auch so geht's bleibt dran